[Música]
não fui convidado para vir falar aqui no
ted meu primeiro impulso foi falar sobre
o futuro dos governos como foi anunciado
falta um tema fabuloso falar sobre
transparência empoderamento cívico
compartilhamento de poder de como a
tecnologia poderá nos transformar em
cidadãos melhores no futuro
mas enquanto eu estava pesquisando sobre
o tema
uma coisa meio mágica aconteceu foi um
estalo
percebi que no fundo eu queria mesmo
falar sobre o futuro dos governos porque
eu estou profissionalmente vinculado a
isso porque eu acredito que eu posso
contribuir para um melhor governo futuro
porque eu acho que eu tenho condições de
contribuir porque eu porque eu eu eu
percebe no fundo bem no fundo uma
verdadeira motivação era a vaidade
lá estava ela novamente a me provocar
a miss fla é que a vaidade tem esse dom
magnífico poderoso ela se uma espécie de
delícia sorrateira que nos acompanha a
todos nós que somos vaidosos e não é
fácil confessar isso o meu pecado
dominante é a vaidade
pensei bom se a proposta do ted a trazer
algo verdadeiro trazer o que nos
entregue por que não falar daquilo que
talvez eu tenho de melhor
a vaidade ea consciência da vaidade é
isso que eu queria falar um pouquinho
aqui pra vocês sobre como é que podemos
aprender com a vaidade e com os nossos
pecados dominantes e volta a falar do
futuro do governo daqui a pouco
bom em primeiro lugar a vaidade é tudo
menos o seu sentido etimológico se forem
agora no dicionário vocês vão encontrar
o que a idade
sinônimo de vazio senão de falso aquilo
que não tem substância real
o sopro dos sopros está tudo
absolutamente equivocado que a vaidade
apesar de sorrateira a vaidade uma força
cauda loja imensa aquática mais ou menos
como um rio de suco nos prega sustos e
armadilhas nas inúmeras quedas d'água ao
longo do percurso
ao mesmo tempo que ela tinha leva que
ela te coloca uma imposição primeira
numa fração de segundos
ela te cega ela te dizia o melhor da
vaidade é sem sombra de dúvida a
autoconfiança uma espécie de messianismo
que tinha empurra a ação que move em
1752 matias aires um grande brasileiro
um grande pensador da vaidade definiu
muito bem isso você tava aqui ea
próximos
o homem de uma medíocre vaidade é
incapaz de premeditar empresas nem de
formar projetos
tudo nele é sem calor a vaidade logo
traz consigo o desembaraço a confiança o
arrojo ea certeza a vaidade nos faz
parecer que merecemos tudo por isso
empreendemos fecha aspas bom é claro que
a vaidade tem seu lado negativo as
formas de geradas a vaidade são a
soberba eo narcisismo é aquela
consciência uma contemplação fã neste
time é exagerada desse mesmo orgulho
excessivo
dizem até que os vaidosos extremos são
porque nada são aliás vinícius de moraes
já cantou sobre isso
cito e um trecho específico ele disse o
homem que diz ou não é porque quem é
mesmo é não sou tão a vaidade
ela de fato tem essa capacidade de de um
outro nos levar a questões que são
absolutamente fantásticas mais
em termos poucos segundos depois nos
desviar nos desviar a atenção e como é
bom sermos levados pelos nossos pecados
dominantes
aliás eu tenho uma teoria eu acho que
todos nós em algum modo hoje em dia
somos muito vaidosos e provo isso aliás
do oeste
vou fazer três perguntas se vocês
disserem sim para 2010 farão parte dessa
minha turma primeiro teste em conta no
facebook no instagram cheque segunda
pergunta já perdi já pesquisou seu nome
no google jack um terceiro teste e se é
verdadeiramente para vaidosos de raiz já
se apresentou com nome sobrenome trazer
rodopiano ou seja desde do governo
hoje em dia todos nós temos uma grande e
boa dose de vaidade
eu me lembro exatamente o dia em que
tive consciência de que vaidade era um
dos meus pecados muito tempo atrás eu me
lembro das horas e horas e horas que
passava em frente ao espelho admirando a
minha franja quando tinham dono e também
lembro também do momento em que tive
plena consciência de que a vaidade era o
meu pecado dominante
isso foi assistir um filme aliás talvez
vocês tenham tido a mesma sensação de si
mesmo
este é muito resumido em uma frase a
frase central do filme que é o vlt é
finito e mais feliz e vaidade
definitivamente o meu pecado favorito é
a frase que fecha o filme advogado do
diabo
quando eu era criança eu quanto os meus
amigos queriam ser astronautas e
bombeiros eu queria ser algo muito
específico presidente do mundo
isso vários momentos me levou a posições
importantes a cargo de liderança mas em
vários outros isso me deixou em
situações absolutamente tristes como por
exemplo o excesso de confiança
arrogância em vários momentos a vaidade
estava lá como sempre esteve à espreita
esperando pra te passar à próxima fase
e aí uma prova disso que nós temos que
ter consciência o tempo inteiro dos
nossos próprios pecados foi que enquanto
eu estava trabalhando a frase
trabalhando o tema da vaidade
estava muito feliz em ter encontrado
alguma coisa para trazer aqui pra você
estava realmente felizes em tentar
trazer algo verdadeiro final de quantas
portas que me diz mudando também expondo
pra todos e nesse processo que estava em
dever sido sobre ter encontrado um ponto
pra falar só aqui pra vocês
escuta uma voz fenit 15º e uma fêmea
disse
ou seja eu tinha caído na armadilha da
vaidade percebe a pegadinha
por pouco eu não tinha caído novamente
na armadilha da verdade e por quê porque
seria muito então vai dar de mim é usar
um pede pra falar da minha vaidade
logo eu comecei a procurar alguma
conexão entre vaidade dimensão coletiva
uma coisa que fizer sentido para mais
pessoas nessa busca de vaidade dimensão
coletiva
algumas outras frases pularam na minha
frente
deus é brasileiro o brasileiro precisa
ser estudado pela nasa
o brasileiro só não conquista o mundo
porque não quer
o brasil é o melhor lugar do mundo
sou brasileiro com muito orgulho com
muito amor
fiquei pensando em montar um bom tema
para a gente pensar quais serão os
nossos pecados favoritos ou pecados
dominantes como o brasileiro aliás será
que a vaidade não é o nosso pecado
coletivo brasileiro dominante
por um lado a gente pensar em futuro do
governo seria de todo ruim
vejamos afinal de contas o exercício do
poder é a expressão maior da vaidade só
com muita coragem dedicação e uma boa
dose de insanidade e de criatividade é
possível exercer política atributos que
não nos falta como brasileiro
mas claro há também o lado ruim
será que essa outra imagem que nós
fazemos nós mesmos não é simplesmente um
artifício para mascarar a nossa posição
com o nosso compreensão eventual de
loser perdedor de um líder da ag
o fato é que é muito difícil chegar a
uma conclusão absoluta sobre isso nesse
exato momento no brasil mas é
extremamente relevante pensarmos fazemos
análise dos nossos verdadeiros pecados e
das nossas também virtudes
por isso que eu gostaria muito de pensar
o futuro dos governos também sobretudo
futuro no brasil a partir da perspectiva
de uma vaidade cívica uma vaidade cívica
isto é conscientes dos riscos mas
impulsionadas por uma ambição coletiva
de tomarmos decisões democráticas que
fundem os pilares das nossas virtudes
públicas e no final das contas a
tecnologia digital nos ajudará
imensamente não há a menor dúvida de que
a tecnologia irá transforma radicalmente
e positivamente o governo as aplicações
tecnológicas são as mais impactantes
e crescem a cada dia mais mas há limites
sempre há limites o governo a política
eo poder jamais serão exercidos pelas
margens por uma combinação inteligente
de algoritmos porquê porque os pecados
assim como as virtudes habitam na
dimensão do insondável
eles ficam na terceira margem do rio
inalcançável por uma combinação de bits
e assim vocês podem até dizer que isso
não passa de uma profissão de fé porque
lido bem com isso
de contas só reforçaria a minha vaidade
como ser humano mas como é importante
termos a consciência ea análise dos
nossos pecados nossas virtudes públicas
porque só assim é que de fato por
poderemos criar algum tipo de antídoto
algum tipo de remédio no final das
contas gente muito tranquilo sem
estresse
tenho certeza de que se tudo é rabo o
futuro dos governos podem me procurar
para ser presidente do mundo
obrigado